But you're definitely feeling
that tobacco, you're feel it's,
it's doing something to your system and
they say it actually has a cognitive
enhancing function that's similar
to nootropics and coffee as well.
That'll like it.
It actually can make you perform better
in tests if you smoked cigarettes or if
you smoke a cigar.
And writers always say that like,
I know a lot of people who write like
writers for sitcoms and stuff like that.
Those guys always smoke cigarettes when
they write and they say they can't write
without smoking. Steven King said
that it's like their weed. Yeah,
well it does have something going on
man, but it's instead of like, it's not,
it's to me it's more like
amped than it is creative.
We'd is super creative.
Weed makes me think of thoughts
while I write them down on my,
I can't even claim that. That's not
even my thought. That's weeds thought.
You know what I mean?
Like I would have never just leave
me by myself with no drugs in a,
in a notebook. I would have never come
up with that idea. But the weeds like,
hey man,
listen to this.
You know the weed weed
is way more of a uh,
like an idea steroid.
I believe it too.
I see people who don't smoke weed and they
write and I'm like who you're so brave
out there out there with no helmet you've
got no life preserver on and now it's
crazy legal everywhere. This amazing
this recreational weed in California.
It's insane. He just walked
nine states now. Yeah. Crazy.
I think 18 states have league illegal
medical and nine states have legal
recreational, nice juice.
It's mass. Yeah it's a wave.
It's going across the whole country.
It's changing everything and it's good.
And you know what the next wave is
MTMA MTMA therapy for PTSD patients has
unprecedented results.
Maps is involved in this,
what does it multiple,
the Multiple Disciplinary Association
for Psychedelic studies or something like
that.
Maps is a amazing a really above board
organization that is at the forefront of
legalization of psychedelics and of
psychedelic research and they'd been
involved in studies with soldiers and
they have amazing results with this stuff.
Mdm May just lets you forgive yourself
and lets you forget everything.
It reprograms your brain had reprogram,
lets you forgive other people in
your life. It changes. It could.
One head of MDM,
MDM and Dma,
that always confuses me,
Molly and said it's a lot easier.
One hint can change your taste
in music forever for ever.
I believe it because before aggregate it,
the first time I did it was 1997 and
before that, how was a DJ at this point?
And I couldn't stand tech.
Now I hated techno music so much and I
was a DJ and anytime a girl went on stage
and she was a tech Nigger, I'm like,
this is because I played drums for real.
So when you listen to techno and house,
it's like it.
That's the most basic dump.
Every song,
every fucking drum beat to Sam.
I couldn't accept it as a musician and
most musicians feel that way about tech
now.
And um,
I went to a birthday party at the key
club in Hollywood and I walk in and
upstairs is techno in downstairs in
the like little bottom club is hip hop.
And it was a birthday party and everyone
was downstairs and me and my buddy Rick,
we walk in and we're standing at the
edge of the techno Floyd and there's like
all these dudes just like
dancing by themselves. They're
just like mental cases,
right. And I was just standing
there looking at him going,
what the fuck is wrong with these people?
Oh my God.
So I went downstairs or playing hip hop,
like that's what I want to hear at clubs.
I want to hear hip hop at a club.
I want to dance with a girl,
not by myself, you know,
so I'm downstairs and then they start
passing around some Molly and some say we
want to do it and I'll never forget
that that first one was blue. I'm like,
I dunno, I dunno. So I took it,
me and my buddy both took it and it hit
us that that first hit just hits you
like a fucking ton of bricks.
We go upstairs and we're on the dance
floor dancing like morons, dude.
And we're looking at each other go, you
get it? I get it, I get it. I get it,
and from that point on, you got all
into trance. Yeah. From that point,
it wasn't just like that night.
It changed my musical
taste right in one hit,
and I had a friend at the club who
was a total rnb duty, hate a techno,
and he would talk shit.
When I played tech and I got one day,
you're going to do some modeling and
you're going to be all into technical as a
fog you. That'll never happen.
I can't stand this music.
He starts dating the raver check
like six months later at the club,
some raver check, he ends up at a
ray, he ends up dropping some Molly,
he starts coming in and bringing
all these new tech, no cds,
and he's all into full blown and the
trends in tech now, just one hint,
this is the real,
the real
problem. It's illegal. So
when you get it from someone,
you don't know what the fuck you getting.
That's the real problem with Molly.
This is a real problem with Mtma.
It's also the dosage.
You don't know what the dosage
is supposed to be. Look,
you can overdose on alcohol
and alcohol's everywhere,
but everybody knows what
the dose of alcohol is,
was you go to a bar and you get a shot
of Jack Daniels. You know what that is?
It's not like sometimes you
get a shot of Jack, Jen,
Jack Daniels in his Jack Daniels.
Sometimes you get it in,
it's super fucking moonshine is
15 times stronger and you die.
That's the problem with heroin.
Yes. A problem with a lot of things.
The real problem with MDM may
seems to be that it's illegal.
That's the real problem and what they're
finding is that there's great benefits
if it's used correctly. I
mean, anything can be abused,
but that doesn't mean we should make
it illegal and what they want to do.
I think their,
their timeline,
it's somewhere around
2021 making it legal for,
for therapy. It's going to change the
world. It's going to change everything.
It's going to change the way people feel
about the past is going to change the
way people interact with each other.
You're going to know just
by people's behavior,
whether or not they've ever done it right.
You know where it comes from.
We're MTMA comes from the part of it,
the active ingredient that takes you
a, that just makes you plant, right?
Where's that planet?
It's in Thailand. Crazy.
Either Thailand or it's like, uh,
what's, uh, Cambodia in Cambodia.
It's like the bark,
like something about that,
like the root of a tree
trunk or something. Yes.
It has something to do with
the tree James pulling it up,
but it becomes very dangerous
for those people. Right?
Like all that the trafficking becomes
crazy. Yeah. There's they fuck up for us.
Like for us are being chopped down. I've
just, just for the people being murdered,
it's like, it's heavy duty
stuff for us. Um, I dunno,
I googled it and just look at
images and that's what popping up.
Maybe it was a place Mtma
Cambodia trees at Sassafras.
Okay. Maybe that is Sassafras
and SEF. Rolly Sassafras. Yeah,
I guess it Sassafras Dude. It's a
whatever. Whatever that plan is.
They take the see if that just Google
vice, uh, the making of ecstasy.
Cause I'm pretty sure vice to
this. But could you go with
that please? I think, uh,
vice had a special on that.
I wonder what would happen if he just
ate it raw. I wonder, can you do that?
Um,
is there a special,
okay,
what does it say?
Okay.
The truth about ecstasy.
Yeah.
So is there some sort of a vice episode
where they grow this stuff anyway?
Um,
this should be something that's not
distributed by criminals were in ski masks
like you've seen in this video.
Should it be something distributed
by stores and they should be doctors?
And if you wanted it,
you could have a rave where you even
have medical centers in the rave.
We keep people from
overdosing. Yeah. When,
when they're the transitionary period
from people going from drugs being totally
illegal to some drugs having
massive benefits. Like if
you're, you go to a club,
right? And everyone there is, c'mon,
we're doing shots were doing shots,
the whole fucking bars getting wasted
and drunk. Everybody's fine with that.
But you're not fine with a club where
everybody does a small amount of ecstasy.
Well, why can't you do that? Well, that's
drugs. Well, the other one's drugs too.
He just used to those drugs.
Once we get past that hurdle,
and it might take a whole generation
before people get used to places where you
can go, one drug gets you
violent, one drug makes you
want to have sex, but listen,
you're not going to stop that drug.
Here's my point. It's a powerful,
really useful drug. People going to find
out about it. It's an amazing experience.
They're going to do it.
So what's the best way to handle that?
Best way to handle is make it safe,
make it legal,
make it regulated so they know what
actually is in each one of these fucking
pills and you're not getting it from
some pimp or some asshole or some fucking
crazy dude is stuffed in and a balloon
put it up as asshole and made it across
the border with it. You don't know where
the fuck you're getting this stuff.
All sorts of shit. All sorts of shit.
Amphetamines and all sorts of crazy shit,
and people die from it because they
don't know what the fuck is in there.
Here it is. Yeah. Um, okay.
It says a boy and load a, p. R.
E w p. H. E n. O. M. Trees.
Murray prove Phnom trees
and Cambodia and the,
they're found in
Cambodia's. Oh, Sassafras.
The factory has been set up
to distill Sassafras oil,
a process by boiling the roots and the
trunk of the exceptionally rare plant. Oh,
they're really rare trees
to, wow. How crazy is that?
How many of these fucking trees?
Or like in the middle of the rain forest?
So we don't know about.